[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hey how's
it going thanks for taking my call
you're welcome how can we
help so I make um about $80,000 a year I
have about $85,000 in Consumer Debt
spread out between a car payment a
personal loan and some credit cards okay
um can you tell us can you tell us how
spreads out just so we know yeah so I
have um 40 thou 43,000 on a uh 2021
truck 24,000 on a personal loan and then
the rest is credit card okay thank
you um back in
September I started working with this
company um that is you know supposed to
negotiate with these credit card
companies and the personal loan company
to help uh bring the balance these debt
settlement relief
companies yes yes
exactly and so at just recently finding
you guys I'm coming to the horrible
realization that this was a bad idea and
to the point where most of these
accounts are defaulted um or you know
not going to work with me personally um
so I don't really know where to go from
there in the baby steps um I have $1,000
spund saved but as far as like tackling
the debt the truck itself is the only
thing that's active if you will pay on
every no so we're selling the truck
first off that's what I'm doing because
a guy who's making 80,000 probably
shouldn't have a car that's more than
half of his annual income that's kind of
just a rule of thumb that we go by
around here and I mean yours is just a
little above but considering your debt
if I were woke up in your shoes the
first thing I would do is sell that car
and I love you so many people call in
James that are upside down in their
vehicles and it kind of puts a wrench in
the plan I mean they're still able to do
it but because you're not upside down if
you sold that car today what would you
get real close regardless um but I I my
my question with that would be is I
travel for work and my vehicle is like
my lifeline um every six weeks to three
months I'm going to a different part of
the country um I build retail stores for
a living um so
I mean having having a vehicle with a
warranty was kind of why I went with a a
new vehicle when I purchased it in the
first place so you're are you you're
hauling things in the truck because of
your work like it's a work
truck yes so you're saying that there's
no way that you could have half the
truck have a $23,000 truck do the same
thing because no I guess that's not the
case yeah cuz I'm not listen I'm not
telling you that you have to get a a
$2,000 truck I'm just saying I think
there's a significant downgrade that you
can do in this situation and I'm saying
that that's what we're working up to
thing one here is we're paying off your
debt that's what we've got that's that's
the house that's on fire that's what
we've got to be focused on and part of
that the reason that your house is on
fire is because you've got a $43,000
truck so if we can knock that down for
the time being five a month or something
if we can knock that down for the time
being to far less expensive that is
going to get you where you want to go
and then the time's going to come where
you can upgrade slowly to get back to a
$40,000
truck sure so would I attack the truck
uh get rid of the truck and then start
working on this debt that's now going to
collections and stop working with this
consolidation company stop giving them
money so what these companies do James
and now you know this is they'll
intentionally tell you hey stop paying
all payments on this let it tank and
then we'll try to negotiate the payment
to make it lower which in turn just
implodes your financial life and really
doesn't solve the problem and by the way
you could have done that
yourself yeah and so these companies are
borderline scam and I hate them with a
burning passion but yeah we need to get
rid of this truck and downgrade for now
which is going to free up a payment you
said how much is the payment on this
truck um it is 835 Oh Lordy listen James
$835 do you know that's so much money
that is so so much money you're going to
be able to make such great Headway um
before you sell the truck obviously
you're going to need to set aside some
cash that you can get a car in cash and
again remember this is just short term
like I understand everything you said
about your your truck being your
livelihood in many ways but this is just
such a short-term sacrifice because with
$835 saved up or you know saved in your
budget every month you're going to be
able to pay off $10,000 $111,000 in
credit cards licky split you're going to
be able to pay off that 20 $24,000 loan
licky split because I know that's not
the only money that you'll be able to
free up to put towards this
debt yeah sure absolutely and James the
other issue with using this truck for
work a new expensive truck is that you
were destroying the value by taking this
thing on the road like that and so you
need to get out of this thing while you
can and you're not underwater he's lucky
he's not already with the with the miles
you put another 10 20 30 40,000 miles on
this thing and that value is just going
to drop like a rock mhm so that's that's
your homework coming out of here your
homework is hey we tell everybody to get
on a budget so make sure you pull out an
every dollar budget that's just going to
help you that's your road map going
forward um and then number two you're
going to start saving up a little bit of
cash so that as soon as possible you can
sell this car and have some cash to get
just an just in the meantime because
once you sell that car it's going to
take you a year to get out of this debt
of or less eight eight I'm going to say
8 to 12 months to pay this off if you
get after it
fair enough okay and yeah and I'm not
entirely alone here I do have a fiance
and two children at home um I have a
seven-year-old and a one-year-old um so
it makes it a little difficult for my
fiance to um you know help in the income
Endeavor as of now we don't really have
strong support Sy system around um but
as well I don't think she should help
you yet because you're not married yet
so until you get married I do even
though you might be living together
financially keep it separate and this is
your debt until you guys get married CBT
because her credit card debt is in total
with that 85000 okay okay so thank you
for the clarification for right now when
do you guys get married together 12
years so oh you've been together 12
years but when do you get
married yeah good question listen James
James you just flipped the entire script
on us right here you done ticked off the
wrong j no I'm not mad I'm not mad I
just wish I had this information sooner
listen number one get married and stop
playing if you've been together 12 years
you got two kids together this is the
woman and if it's not real wedding and
it's just not in the in the table I get
that but literally just get the piece of
paper because this is for legal
protection for both of you and if you
guys want to do the party later that's
fine but get the piece of paper so that
you can combine your money and it's safe
for both of you like just talk and be
like listen girl we've been together all
this time come down to the courthouse
with me let's get this paper signed you
don't even have to anyone all right that
can be your little secret until it's
this is just to keep you safe under the
law of combining your things together
because if something happens you want to
show that you were legally married
Financial legal protections with
marriage so that's right so that's you
got some more to do
James James thanks for telling us you
just he just entered the fire by telling
us last minute 12
years listen get a Costco pizza and a
Costco cake and we'll celebrate later
listen they don't even have to tell
anybody just go get the D gum
certificate don't tell anyone and then
when you you can pretend like oh we're
we set a date and we're getting married
like nobody knows at this point they
forgot I mean they don't they're like 12
it's been 12 Years everybody around them
thinks that they're married yeah that's
crazy listen if you're listening I don't
care if you've been dating for 8 years
or 2 24 years if you don't have that
piece of paper and something goes wrong
you are not protected get married get
the piece of paper so that if something
goes ay the law is on your side to make
sure you get your cut come on ladies
this is the Ramsey Show create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life